thanks for joining me today
my name is hassan barakat and i work as
a tech lead with a company here in
sydney called willow
this is my twitter handle and website if
you would like to follow me or reach out
to me with any questions that you have
today i would like to talk to you about
practical domain driven design with ef
core
if you have any questions during the
call or the talk
please feel free to send the questions
on a slack i will look into all of the
questions
after the talk and i will answer them
there
i've been practicing domain driven
design for a long time now and one of
the common challenges that i have found
when i work it alongside other
developers is how can we apply the
domain driven design concepts to a
legacy code base that we have inherited
from a previous team or a previous
company or third party vendor that's
basically worked on that code base
and that's going to be the focus of my
talk today how can we apply
the domain driven design into a legacy
code base
and we will be using ef core to make
sure that that domain model that we will
be building
can be materialized into a relational
database
let's start by defining what's doing
driven design
wind-driven design is an approach to
software development that centers the
development on programming domain model
that has a rich understanding of their
processes and the rules of the domain
so as developers will be building a
domain model that domain model will have
business rules and processes or will
help us to solve
that particular problem that we are
trying to solve so what's the domain
model
a domain model is an object model of the
domain that has both behavior
and data so basically we will be
building classes to represent the domain
our classes will have behavior which is
usually represented with methods in
c-sharp
and it will also have data which are
usually represented with properties
there is another key definition for the
domain model which is it's a system of
abstraction that describes
selected aspects of a domain and can be
used to solve the problems
related to that domain so as developers
we will not be representing
every single aspect that exists in the
business domain that we are working on
we will focus on the areas that will
help us solve the business problem
over time our domain model or our
classes will keep growing and growing
and this will make it harder to
understand
and difficult to maintain thanks to
domain driven design there is a solution
for that which is using the strategic
design pattern
the idea is pretty simple but it's
usually hard to apply at the beginning
which is
when you have a big system you usually
want to split that system
into a set of bounded contexts
bounded context is a defined part of a
software where particular terms
definitions and rules
apply in a consistent way it also
provides us with a clear boundary
between different parts of the system
so as we can see here we have two
bounded contexts
sales and support each of them have
different terms
and each one has a clear
definition that can be understood by
both developers and business experts
some of the terms that exist in the
pounded context of sale exist
also in support like customer or product
the meaning might slightly differ
between the different bounded contexts
but the key thing here is
both business stakeholders and or domain
experts and developers have the same
understanding
our focus today will be how can we split
a big system into
set of grounded contexts but we will
focus on how can we apply
the main driven design the tactical
parts into a particular bounded context
but which one should we start with when
we have multiple bounded contexts we
should start focusing on the core domain
the core domain is the bounded context
that provides the most value for your
for your company so it's that part of
the system if you removed it your
company wouldn't
exist that's usually where you where you
try to start
and this is where you should be applying
all of the concepts like
services entities value objects and
repositories
but this doesn't help us actually solve
how can we factor a legacy code based
tools that all of those concepts to be
applied in there
and this is where we'll spend the rest
of the talk today showing you how it
will refactor an existing
legacy codepiece but before we do that i
just want to remind you that you
shouldn't apply domain-driven design for
every bounded context
you need to assess the value that you
will get from applying the wind driven
design to a particular branded context
because
by nature some of the founded context
might be just crowd-based operation like
maintaining a product catalog with their
names
categories and not much business rules
like
around the pricing or things like that
so
in that case if it's just a crowd based
operation you will not get much
value of applying the domain driven
design
sometimes some of the domains are might
be uh specific to me like the search
if you have a search you might be bitter
using an existing service like
elasticsearch or whatever product that
exists it solves this problem
and you might not get much value from
applying domain driven design in that
particular domain
so keep that in mind you shouldn't be
applying the main driven design for
every bounded context
so let's start by showing how can we
refactor a legacy code base
towards more of a rich domain model and
we will be applying that by using a
sample domain that i have extracted from
a recent project that i have worked on
i have simplified really made it very
very simple
to make it easy to go through the code
base and some of the smells that we can
find in the code and
how can those code smells help us reflex
refactor the code towards more of a rich
domain model
our sample domain will be a florist
website
that flourish website enables the
customers to subscribe to products
such as a small weekly punch large
weekly punch and each product
would have a price and one of the other
things that
business rule is the more amount of
money the customer
can portal they will get a discount
based on that money spent
the business rules that we have right
now will go through the journey of a
customer subscribing to a product
and how can we improve the code base
that's covering that area of
customer subscribing to a particular
product
our current domain model that we will be
working with we have a customer
that customer has email first name last
name the amount of money spent so
whenever they subscribe to a product we
can identify
the right discount that they will get we
have a product where we have the name
paying period if it's weekly or monthly
and the amount for that product
whenever a customer subscribed to a
product
that generates a subscription and that
subscription will have the actual amount
that the customer purchases this product
with when this product will
expire using the current period in date
and then we have a status
which is either active or cancelled
immediately once you so once you see
this domain model you can say
actually this domain model doesn't
satisfy the definition that we said
about the domain model that to have both
behavior
and data because as we can see here we
only have
data it's only properties in that
particular domain
so let's switch to the ide to go through
the code and
showing you how can we refactor towards
rh domain model
here is my ide i'm using jetbrainwriters
for today and our code is written in
c-sharp
and its.net core api we'll be using.net
and e45
the source code of this repository
before the refactoring after the
refactoring is available in github i
will share the links towards the end of
the talk
so here is our controller we have a
request
for a customer to subscribe to our
product we are using the excellent
library mediator from jimmy bogard and
this is
right now becoming commonly used in a
lot of code bases it provides us with
that benefit to make our controllers
really
small and we have the business logic in
uh class to handle a particular request
so we have that request and we have a
request handler to go through
we'll go through all of the logic of how
a customer subscribe to our product in a
minute
just go through the rest of the classes
that we have in our project
we are using a of course we have a db
context that includes
three properties one for each table
we have the domain directory that
includes the classes that we have seen
in the diagram
as we can see it's just properties in
here
and we have a base entity that includes
an id which is
the primary key of my entities and we
have a service which is sending an email
which is just pretty much doing nothing
but it just gives us
that sample of if we would like to have
a side effect like signaling an email or
sending an sms
let's get back to our request handler
to see what's actually happening in
there also
before we start we have an integration
test that we'll be using to make sure
that
our code as we refactor it is not broken
and this is really important with any
code base that you are working on
so here is our customer subscribing to a
product
we are loading a customer from the
database loading the product
then we are calculating the subscription
amount and that
is based on the amount of money spent by
the customer if the customer spent more
than 100 dollars
then they get a 20 discount if they
spend more than
or equal one thousand they get fifty
percent discount
it's really simplified but it will just
convey the idea of the rules that could
apply whenever a customer subscribed to
approval
then we are calculating whenever a
subscription will expire
is on the pelling period of a product so
if it's a weekly we add
seven days if it's a monthly one month
the next section in this method is
creating a subscription
setting the progress of that
subscription adding it to the customer
subscriptions
increasing the amount of money spent
saving everything in the database
after that we send an email to the
customer letting them know that they
have subscribed to upload
this is a common pattern that you see in
a lot of code pages
and one of the first things that i see
with this method it's a long method i
can't even fit it on
a single screen i'm using a large font
but even if i
use a smaller phone it will be hard to
have everything
in your mind when you work with such
long method
and the first thing that i do when i
have such long methods i break them into
smaller ones by applying the extract
method refactoring so i can minimize the
cognitive load that i require when i
work with this code base
usually in legacy code bases you find
comments or regions that
that's kind of the smell that will hint
you to start where to
where and how to create that long method
so the first thing we will do we just
extract that section which is
calculating subscription amount
then the next part here is calculating
the current period in date so i'll
extract this to another method
the last part here is creating a
subscription and adding it to the
customer
so we extract a method and we call it
add subscription to customer
here you go so right now as you can see
the method
is broken and it's much shorter still
there is a lot of things to be improved
and we'll see as we go how can we
improve that logic right now
so let's start looking at the methods
that we have extracted
but before we do this since we have done
a refactoring let's make sure that we
didn't bring the code as part of that
refactoring by running the integration
tests
and that is pass let's start by looking
at this first missile that we have
extracted
we create a subscription we add it to
the customer subscriptions increase the
amount of management
as i read this through this method i can
identify few good smells
the first one with creating the
subscription we are using the property
setters
to initialize the subscription and we
are using the object initializer but the
key part here is
we are setting the properties directly
and
as a consumer of that domain model
nothing is stopping me from creating the
subscription
in an invalid state so i can create a
subscription and i cancel this date
technically that's valid but from a
business perspective
there is no such thing as creating
subscription in cancel it's usually
either
active or maybe if you didn't collect
the money you will create it impending
after getting the money you will make it
active
in our domain it's either active or
canceled and the default is active
so that's an issue right we wanna we
want the code to help us as consumers
of that domain model to avoid making
those mistakes
nothing stopping me from creating
subscription with a negative amount
or a subscription without a customer or
product if i did that i will get an
error when i save that data into the
database because there is a
relation between the tables that might
be broken but i don't want to
wait till that last minute when i get an
exception from the database
i want to have all of these validation
rules as part of my domain model
and the good thing with c-sharp is we
can do this by using a constructor so i
can go here in my subscription class
i will update all of the properties to
be privately set
so only methods inside my subscription
entity
can change the values of those
properties
and i will introduce a parameterized
constructor
where i can pass the required parameters
to initialize a subscription entity
to avoid having spending a lot of time
with the writing
and all of the spinning mistakes i have
bunch of good snippets that i will be
using today
so here we go we have our subscription
constructor
where i added the validations of the
customer product amount
i even set the default value for the
status i updated all of the progresses
to be privately set as well
with that a change i will update the
consumer code to use that parameterized
constructor
and with this refactoring let's run the
test to make sure that nothing is broken
and we manage it to create the tests
the error that we are seeing here is
basically ef core
unable to load that entity from the
database because this is a limitation
that we have unfortunately for right now
when you have a constructor with some of
the complex type
it cannot use that parameterized
constructor
so the solution to that is to use a
private constructor
that can be used by ef core
and we are using private constructor
here parameter less constructor because
that can be used by af core but the
consumers of my code
still has to use that constructor with
parameters
so it's we kind of satisfying both ef
core
and the consumers of my code i know that
some developers prefer to have two
domain models
like having a subscription domain model
that have all of the business rules
and maybe another model to include
anything relevant to ef4
in my experience working with basical
business i find that
over time it it's much easier to work
with those
existing entities move behavior into
them but again that depends on the code
base
and if you are working with two domain
models and having a lot of mapping
that's up to you to decide but
in today's talk we'll be going through
updating the existing entities of the
domain model
so now let's run the tests
and the tests pass
let's get back to our request handler to
see that method
the second second code smell that i can
see here is
there is that relationship between the
subscriptions and the money spent
so right now whenever as a developer i
modify the subscriptions
i need to remember to update the money
spent
and that's not really a good thing
because it's usually the source of bugs
because i might end up adding a
subscription and not updating the
amounts
of money spent i update the money spent
and i forget to update subscription
and so on and so forth so ideally
those properties should also be
privately set and modified by behavior
inside an entity
and if we read those three lines this is
basically like adding a subscription to
customer even the method name kind of
giving us this
hint so we can basically move this whole
behavior to be part of the customer
entity
and we update those two properties to be
privately set and they cannot be
modified
outside the customer entity and this
means that
when we move that to be part of the
customer the consumers of my codepath
will not have to remember they don't
need to remember that whenever i update
a subscription i update the money spend
they just
want to call add subscription
so let's do that i will move this method
by making it many static
and i will make it an instance method of
the customer
so now this method is part of the
customer i can rename it
and remove that two customer suffix
[Music]
there we go so we have moved the
behavior to be part of the customer
this enables us to make the money spent
as a private property
private set and we need to do the same
thing for subscription
the only difference here is subscription
is a list and to make the
subscription list exposed as a read only
we need to we can use something like i
read only collection which is a page
interface that the list class inherits
from
however the problem with that is the
consumers can easily
cast back to an ex to a list and use all
of the methods in that list
so in order to properly expose an
immutable subscriptions list what we are
going to do is we will use a private
packing field for this property
so we'll introduce a packing field and
i'll just move that
field closer to the property
i will update my behavior inside the
customer class to use that private
packing field
i don't need that setter because we are
going to make it a read only
so i'll remove that setter and we can
move this to be
expression body and now we have that
private backing field
i can modify this property to be
i read only collection
still nothing is stopping me from a
consumer perspective
to do something like customer after i
add a subscription i can go and say
customer dot subscriptions
very smart so we can go and cast as list
of subscription and when i do this
i can call it clear right nothing is
stopping me from doing something like
we shouldn't but you know we
nothing stopping us from doing it and
it's pretty easy to cover that scenario
as well
by going here and using the as read-only
method
so even though the compiler will not
complain
immediately in the runtime if we run the
tests or
if we run this code we will get a
runtime exception
so it's pretty easy to cover the
scenario by using the as read only as
part of my method
let's get back to the slides to see what
we have done so far
and then we will see what other good
smells we can have
the first thing that we have done is
minimize the cognitive load required
from us as developers by breaking that
long method into smaller ones
which provided us with the three methods
that we have worked with which is
calculate the subscription amount
current period indeed and add the
subscription to customer
we started looking at the method add
and that enabled us to start avoiding
the public sectors when we are creating
a new subscription entity
and we moved to a parameterized
constructor
which enabled that to add validation we
added the default value for the status
as well
we have moved all of our properties to
be privately set
next we have pushed the behavior of
adding subscription to be part of the
customer
so this tells us that usually in those
legacy code bases that the behavior
exists
but it might not be part of the domain
model in our case it existed in the
request handler
in other legacy code bases it could be
part of a domain server a domain service
is a valid point i should say just a
service or a utility
uh or sometimes an extension method so
usually when you have those kind of
anemic domain model the behavior exists
but we just need to move it to the
domain model which is the right spot for
it
we have updated our subscription and
management to be privately set so the
money spent we use the private set for
the property
and we use a private packing field for
the subscription list
made it immutable by exposing it via i
read only collection
and to avoid any runtime casting back to
a list we
used as read only here which will throw
an exception for any consumer
let's get back to the code and look into
the next method that we have extracted
and how can we improve it
the next method here is calculate the
current period indeed
and this method is interesting because
it's a static method that accepts a
single parameter
and all of the code that exists in that
method depends only on that past
parameter
this is usually a smell that tells me
that this whole behavior
should be an innocence method of that
particular clause
especially it's a domain model it's the
male model entity that exists
so what i would do right now is i would
refactor this method
and we will make it an instance method
of the product
so we're kind of pushing more behavior
towards my domain model
now opening the product class
we can see here our instance method
one thing to keep in mind this method
have a switch statement over a c-sharp
enumerator which is the filling period
in our case we only have a single touch
point where we have that's with
switch statement however in a lot of the
legacy code pages you might find
there are heaps of touch points in your
code base that have that switches
statement
or if else condition on an enumerator
and that usually makes it harder if you
would like to introduce
another value in my enumerator if i
would like to introduce quarterly or
yearly
i need to go and find all of those such
points and update them
usually when when you find such pattern
in or smell in your code
you should you should refactor from a
c-sharp enumerator into
enumeration classes we will not cover
that today because we only have a single
touch point so it would be over
complication
but it's just something that you need to
keep in mind when you work with
legacy code bases that have a lot of
switch statements over enumerator
so as you can see with this change we
have more behavior pushed into our
domain model
and we should run the tests because i
forgot to run it in the last refactoring
sorry for that
here we go the tests are still passing
let's get back to the code and see what
we have right now the third method that
we have extracted
this method is also static and it
accepts two parameters both of them
are entities in my domain model
however the logic here of calculating
subscription amounts
might not really belong to one of them
because i need both
entities and the values from both
entities to calculate the outcome
and this is usually an indication that
we should use a domain service
which is basically a service that can
hold a business logic
when we have a logic that cannot really
fit into a single entity in my domain
and that's what we are going to do right
now we create a domain service we will
call it
subscription amount calculator
and i will move this method that we have
here to that
domain service
so as we can see with this refactoring
we have uh
the method become a static method of the
calculator i'll just run the test to
make sure that nothing is broken
another thing that usually find with
those services
is i would like to still have my unit
tests
to be able to market the domain service
so i can test different paths
or different outcomes from the domain
service that can be easily achieved by
introducing a
base interface for my domain service
so i'll create the interface here it
writers
do that for me and then i will update
the method and make it manistatic
and will pull this member up
so it will just add that method to the
interface so we have here
we have the interface with the calculate
subscription amount
then in my code a request handler
obviously i need to inject that
interface
via my constructor
i will introduce a field and then i will
use that field to call the method rather
than calling
the static method that we used to have
so this enables me to register that page
interface into my
di container and resolve it from the i
container
and it also enables me in my test to
mock
the behavior and test different paths in
my code base
speaking of test let's fix that and
introduce the parameter that we just
introduced into the request handler and
since it's an integration test i will
just use the actual
method so i will pause the concrete
implementation of the interface
running the tests
so far so good so as you can see
all of the three methods that we have
extracted so far
will actually belonging to different
parts of my domain
and what we have done is step by step
finding the code smells
pushing the code towards the domain
model so my domain model right now have
more
behavior into it so it becomes more data
and behavior as we would like it to be
let's review this request handler we can
see here we have
two lines the last two methods that
we're working on calculate the
subscription amount
and then calculating the current period
indeed we are using the outcome of those
methods and pathing to add subscription
however there's something interesting
with those two lines the first line here
of calculating the current period in
date
is just calling a method of the product
passing the outcome to another method
that accepts the product as a parameter
so this usually tells me that i can push
this line of code to be part of the add
subscription
so let's do that first i will unline the
variable so the call of the method
becomes
part of the call of the ad subscription
then in the ad subscription i will just
directly call instead of
calling the method here or using the
parameter path
i will just do it as part of the whole
to the constructor of the subscription
this means that this parameter is no
longer required i can safely remove it
again looking at that line of code of
the subscription i can see that
i'm passing the outcome of that
calculate current period and date to the
subscription constructor which is
also accepting the product as a
parameter so i can do the same thing
which is
adding or calling this method directly
in the constructor which means
that parameter is useless and i can
remove it safely
so as you can see the code is driving
how can i move the behavior towards
which part of the domain model and now
removing that parameter means
in order to create a subscription entity
list parameter is required
so it makes the code more easier to
maintain
let's run the tests
pistons are possible the second line
here that we talked about
is slightly complicated because it
depends on that domain service that we
are resolving
from the di container
so but still it accepts product and
customer
and i have the product as well as the
customer as part of my ad subscription
method
so in order to push that behavior to be
part of the domain model
while maintaining that capability of
resolving that
the interface via the di container which
also enables me to
smoke different behaviors or different
outcomes of the calculate method
i can use the double dispatch pattern
the double dispatch pattern enables me
to
instead of passing the outcome of the
domain service
i will pass the domain service itself as
a parameter to my
method here so i will
just align this variable so when we
delete the
parameter it just becomes easy and then
i will pause the calculator itself as an
additional parameter
i will use add parameter and then go
into that add subscription method i have
the calculator
so instead of passing the subscription
amount i'm gonna go and call
calculate subscription amount
this accepts two parameters the product
which i have and then it needs the
customer
and the customer is basically my class
so i can just use this
with that that subscription amount
parameter is no longer required
and calling the domain server method
becomes part of my domain model
and i still can resolve that domain
service via the di container and
inject it to my request hand
so as you can see with these
refactorings
my request handler is much much smaller
right now so this tells me that all of
the behavior that existed in here
previously
should have been part of the domain
model and in a lot of legacy code bases
that's usually the case that behavior
exists either in the controller or a
service or
a request handlers like what we have
seen here
let's get back to the slides to see the
refactorings that we have done so far
with the calculate the current period
end date we move the behavior to be part
of the product entity
with the domain behavior of calculating
subscription amount we introduced the
domain service to encapsulate that logic
because the logic didn't really fit into
a single entity
we have also used the double dispatch
pattern to pass
the domain service to my domain model
which also enables me to still
inject that interface via the di
container into my request header
let's get back to the code the last line
of the code here
is sending the email and usually in
legacy code pages or even in
any copies you can you can find bunch of
side effects that happen
because a customer subscribed to a
product or something that has happened
in my domain
and it's an application level
responsibility it's not part of my
domain model to send an email
so what should i do with those code how
can i make my code
open for extension because if i would
like to add another behavior like
sending an sms
i need to add a few lines of code here
to send an sns
if i want to let's say at a record of
audit entry or something
again i need to have another line of
code here and so on and so forth
the solution to that is to start
introducing the domain
events and having domain event handler
domain events usually used to represent
the intent that something has happened
in the domain
and we don't care who is interested in
listening to those domain events
as a domain model we just need to raise
that domain event
and then we have bunch of event handlers
that listens to that domain event
so if i would like to have a send the
email functionality i will have a
an email sender handler that will listen
to the domain event
send an email if i would like to extend
the functionality by adding another
behavior
i can just add another event handler for
the sms
another event handler to do something
else and so on
to introduce the domain events into my
code base we will do few steps
uh it's a little bit involved so i will
cover that by the slides first
and then we'll see how we applied in the
code
first we will update our entity so
whenever a behavior is called like a
customer subscribing to a product
we will add a domain event we will raise
the domain event
so in our entity or each entity in my
domain we'll have a list of domain
events
we'll do this by updating our page base
class to include a list of domain events
and because any change that happen in my
domain usually needs
a save to a save to the changes to the
database so this mean
since we are using ef core we will be
calling the save changes
right so what we can do is we can use
the af core 5
save changes interceptor to listen to
that call of save changes
and that will be kind of the domain
event dispatcher
that will use the change tracker
functionality from efcor
to publish the domain events that exist
in the entities we'll be using the
publish method from mediator
which enables us to have that pops up
mechanism even though it's in memory but
it provides us with that pops up so i
can have multiple event handlers
for the same event that's what we're
gonna do
so let's switch back to the code first
we need to introduce page interface
where all my domain events
inherit from
since my domain events will be published
to mediator i will use
i will make this inherit from i
notification
i can immediately make my domain events
inherit from i notification but i think
that
using that marker interface makes it a
little bit clearer
since we said we want to maintain list
of domain events in the entity i will
update
the page entity
to maintain a list of domain events and
similar to what we have done with the
list of subscriptions in the customer we
are exposing this via
an immutable list and you can modify the
behavior
of those who just add or update via
methods
in that entity
now we have that page interface and the
page entity include a list of domain
events let's introduce our first domain
event which is a customer subscribe to a
product
and as you can see i'm using the past
tense in my domain event
and this is usually how you describe
your domain events it usually want to
describe
something that has happened in the past
i i have a good snippet with the domain
event and how the handler would look
like so we don't
write all of that
import the references so my domain event
just inherits from i domain event
has two properties customer id product
id
and then i have a customer subscribe to
a product handler
in this case it just send an email so i
kind of moved the behavior of email
sender
from the request handler to be part of
the event handler
so this mean i can update my request
handler to remove
that logic because that will be
triggered by the event handler as we
will see in a minute
i'll just remove this line of code
and i no longer need this parameter
and no longer need this field as well
because i have moved that logic to be
part of my event handler
so right now we have an event we have an
event handler
we need to update our entity so whenever
a customer subscribed to a product we
need to raise that domain event
by calling the add domain event method
so each time we add a subscription we
update the list of domain events
that exist in my entity so far
we have an domain events in my entity
and we have event handler that can
handle
that event whenever it's raised the last
piece is blowing those together
using the save the changes interceptor
from ef core
i have that behavior here as well
instead of writing it i'll just
uncomment and we'll read it together
so this is my domain event dispatcher
which is listening to
the save it changes saving the changes
so this means that the
events that we are publishing will be
published before
the entities have been saved into the
database
and that might raise concerns because
what if i sent the email and failed to
save the data into the database because
of some network issue
usually after i use this pattern i
apply another pattern to improve the
resiliency of publishing the domain
events which is called store and forward
or
outbox pattern we will not cover that
today but
i highly recommend looking into that
pattern because it will definitely
improve the way you publish the main
events and it will improve the
resiliency of that
so you don't have that concern around
did i save the events
and for or do they publish the events
and failed to save the entities in the
database
so in our case we are using just in
memory pops up so our we use the change
tracker
to find all of the entries in the
changes tracker with domain
events loop over the domain events and
publish them
to mediator mediator will find all of
the event handlers
and will send them that particular event
running the tests obviously i don't have
tests
in this code base right now for the
domain event dispatcher or for the event
handlers that we have introduced
but ideally as you refactor your code
bait you should update your
your tests either they are integration
or unit based on what you are working
on so with that we can see that
our code is right now with the request
handler
it's pretty straightforward loading data
from the database
calling a behavior in my domain model
saving that savings
one last thing that i want to cover with
that saving the changes interceptor
how would you register that in the gi
container
because my domain event dispatcher have
another dependency that we would like to
resolve
in the runtime from the di container
which is imediator
what i want to do here in the startup i
need to
register the domain event dispatcher as
a scope because this matches my db
context
and then when i'm adding the dbcontext
there is an overload here that accepts a
service provider
which means i can easily go and say
serviceprovider.getservice
and this will enable me to resolve the
domain even dispatcher from the di
container
which will also resolve any dependencies
for my domain event dispatch
so that's what that's how can we
introduce the domain events in my domain
in my model
let's get back to the slides
so as we said we had an entity whenever
a behavior
happens to the entity we raise the
domain event listen to that save the
changes from db context
use the save it changes interceptor to
publish the domain events by a mediator
and we could have
multiple event handlers for my domain
event
as we have seen so far all of the
triggers for the refactoring is the code
and that's really good because all of
the code smells have been driving those
refactorings and we are pushing more
behavior into my domain model
but that's not the only reason or the
only trigger that i would have
refactoring in my code base when we work
in a domain driven design you usually
have
a lot of conversations with business
experts and one of the key concepts with
domain driven design is using ubiquitous
language so
both developers and business experts or
domain experts
use the same language and it's not only
in conversation my code
should also show those behaviors or you
show the same language as well so a very
simple example is
when we talk with business experts they
keep using the word customer name
like i would like to send an email to
the customer with the customer name
and that particular content or i would
like to have a report and i would like
to show the customer name and the amount
of money spent
for that customer and they never use
that customer first name last name
however if we look at our code we will
find
that our code is just all about first
name last name
and this might be a good trigger to
start updating my domain model
to use the same language used by the
business experts
so in this case we can use something
like value objects
value objects provides us with that
capability where we have two objects
can be equivalent when they have the
same value without being the same
object so if i have two instances of the
customer name
if both instances have the same value
for the first name and last name
those instances will be equal even
though they are not the same object
thinking about that with the c-sharp 9
this is pretty much
the records in c sharp 9. and that's
what we're gonna do right now
we'll just introduce a record to
represent the customer name
so here is our customer name record
then i will update my customer class to
use that customer name
customer name can also be used in a
parameterized constructor
and i can make it with a private set
so i will just update my properties
similar to what we have done with the
subscription entity
so here we go we have a private
constructor to be used by af core when
loading entities from the database
we have a parameterized constructor to
be used by developers consuming the
domain model
and we have the validations here while
we are creating the customer entity
i have also made the customer name
private wizard
the next thing that we need to think
about with that customer name recorded
change is
how can i save that customer name into
the database with ef code
if call provides that concept that's
called owned empties
which enables us to map those value
objects
into the same columns that we used to
have in the previous
sample with the code base of property of
customer name and last name
so on the entities we just use owns one
and then we map the property first name
to the column first name and last name
to the last name
one of the important things to keep in
mind when you work with only entities
is the default convention it uses a
customer name underscore first name
excuse me
or customer name underscore last name so
we have to be explicit with which column
we are saving the properties to
the second thing that you need to keep
in mind is you need to keep an eye on
the generated sql statements
when you use on the entities and make
sure that it's generating
the right sql statement because you
don't want to end up with performance
issues because you use the wrong
configurations
with that let's update the customer name
to be used here in my code to pass the
customer name
instance let's run the test to make sure
that everything is working as expected
cool now we have the customer name let's
get back to the slide to see what we
have done
we have moved away from the primitive
obsession of using
string for the first name string for the
last name and move towards
value objects which enabled us to use
the same ubiquitous language that our
business experts are using
which also enabled us to have that c
sharp
record to represent our value object we
used the on the entities to map our
properties
to the same columns that we used to have
previously
one of the things that i want i will
mention here with af core 5
is that navigation that is required this
is really a cool addition in af core 5
which enables us to have a clear
definition
that if some of the columns that we are
working with are required
or mandatory on the database level we
can use the is required
property and when we run the ef core to
generate the migrations if you are using
af core migrations
those migrations will be generated
correctly previously with af core 3.1
there was issues that all the entities
were always assumed to be nullable
which was generating bunch of migrations
that are not
matching what we want to have if we have
required columns
the next thing that i would like to talk
about is the repository
in a lot of legacy code bases you might
find repositories
repositories in general are okay it's a
good pattern
however with a lot of the legacy code
pages i usually find two key issues the
first one is the massive amount of
methods that exist in a repository line
get customer by first name give customer
by last name discussion by first name
email and last name and so on
and the second parameter is or the
second concern
is that something like that saved method
which is calling context.save changes
context to save the changes since all of
the entity related
all of the entities not just the entity
of the customer
to the database so if i have a little
bit of a complex behavior that uses
multiple repositories and i call
the save method from different
repositories i might end up with all
sorts of errors
because i saved in the wrong timing or
data inconsistencies
and it usually becomes pretty messy very
quickly
so what i have seen as pattern is to
solve that save method is using the unit
of work
the unit of work is a solution for that
issue because we no longer have that
same method as part of the repository it
just becomes part of the unit of work
which
abstracts that subscription context or
the db context
however if we think about it the
subscription context itself
is a unit of war and it's a clause that
we are maintaining
so instead of introducing introducing a
wrapper
for our subscription context what we can
use is we embrace the dbcontext class
to be our unit of work and in that we
can have
all sorts of methods like begin
transaction commit
rollback whatever we want we can just
add it in here
and for testing perspective we can make
that subscription context and headed
from an interface
so that i can test different behaviors
for my db context
so this will help us with the unit of
work and getting
around that same method that existed in
the repository
however that doesn't help us with the
massive amount of methods that
exist in the repository there are
different patterns that can help us with
improving that i'll not be able to cover
all of them today
but like something like query clauses or
specification pattern or extension
methods
but i will quickly skim through a couple
of examples with
specification pattern and extension
methods really quickly go through them
there are sample code in the github
repository that will explain
both patterns and i'll share the links
at the end of the talk
let's have a look at this example query
this is
could be just a query and a repository
to get an active subscriptions
for a particular customer so we are
getting a subscription that has the
status active
for a particular customer id and we do
the mapping to return the entity to the
database
what we have in here usually end up with
large query conditions large query
closes so you might have
and or and parents here and there
so that query usually gets bigger and
bigger and that's why you end up with
having this as a method and you want to
have you don't want to
kind of repeat that method multiple
times and you wrap that as a part of
your repository
but it's usually not readable because
even within the same repository you
might have two different methods
and you might end up repeating the same
conditions in those two methods inside
the same repository
because of a slight difference
and the solution to that could be
introducing a specification pattern
you have a page specification where you
identify
what is the criteria like the where
clause that will be used
that includes to find which other tables
you will load from the database
you can also extend this to include like
the sorting
or vagination and so on for now we just
have the
criteria as an example
with that basic specification class i
kind of start creating concrete
specifications like get the active
subscriptions
becomes a class where i define the
criteria and obviously with more complex
i can
apply the pagination logic i can apply
the sourcing and
different things that i would like to
add i can have another specification for
the customer
subscriptions with those two
specifications i can have my own
my own word method that accepts the
specification
and this will as you can see here where
new active subscription is specification
and since the specification is
um isolated i can reuse it across
different queries
and the good thing is with that
specification pattern
the generated sql statement is exactly
the same that was used
when we use the where conditions
directly
so we have a more usable approach and i
can share different specifications and
it becomes more of a lego right i use
different specifications to
build my own query
however with more complex specifications
this becomes a little bit
more harder to read and the class names
gets bigger and bigger
the good thing is we can leverage
extension methods
to make our code more readable and
encapsulate that behavior
so i can have something like context dot
subscriptions that get active
subscriptions for customer so this is
basically get active subscription is
an extension method that's wrapping that
where method
and for customer is wrapping that
where new customer specification so my
code becomes
much more readable and i can reuse those
specification concrete classes as a
label
there are different approaches as well
that can help with with that but the key
thing here is
with this change in the code i can
basically
sometimes not even need to have a
repository in my codebase
the next thing that i would like to talk
about is having a base entity id my
classes
as you have seen inherit from a base
entity which have primary key of geoid
in legacy code bases you might have a
mix of tables that were using
integers which were created previously
and new tables using
different data type like guid you can
solve this by using a page entity that's
a generic
but even better you can take this one
step forward we are using a strongly
typed
entity id like subscription id here
that enables me first to add validation
so i can
create only subscription id if it's not
empty
it also enables me to avoid errors by if
i have a method that accepts two geo ids
i can pretty easily send the longer id
to the wrong parameter so i can send the
customer id to the product id parameter
and vice versa but if i'm using a
strongly typed id
i am leveraging the static type features
of the c sharp
because the compiler will complain if i
passed customer id
to a product id there are a bunch of
other benefits when you work with entity
id like refactoring from the old integer
id
to the new gid with your tables that
could also
make your refactoring a bit easier it
might not be the first thing that you
will do when you move towards
more of a domain driven design domain
model or a rich domain model
but it's something that you really need
to keep in mind and you try to
push to it as you progress with your
refractions
that's all what i wanted to cover today
the slides are
available i will share the link on slack
the demos also include all of the code
that we have seen today with uh
before refactoring and after refactoring
if you are looking more into that
specification pattern i have recently
found this
uh stevie smith specification library
which is doing a lot of
covering of the behavior for different
specifications with includes
pagination sorting all sorts of things
thanks a lot for your time uh i will
look into the questions that we have
that you have sent over slack and i will
answer
them there again thanks again for your
time
i wish you enjoyed the talk uh please
feel free to reach out with any
questions that you have later
uh over twitter or slack thanks again
and enjoy the rest of the conference